you
the Iranian missile strike on a US base
in Iraq last week left dozens of
American troops with traumatic brain
injuries some of which were slow to be
diagnosed it's just one example of the
kind of invisible injury addressed by a
pioneering government program only on
CBS this morning
catherine herridge got an inside look
Catherine good morning Tony good morning
is so rare to hear directly from these
special operations forces who take on
some of the most difficult missions and
as the nation leans on them and their
families once again this unique program
is helping them to heal and stay in the
fight one of my first appointments to
Afghanistan I we had a very rough go of
it you lost a lot of your team at the
time I didn't realize how traumatic it
was to me and then years later I'm still
thinking about it and I'm still dealing
with it after eight major deployments
since 9/11 Green Beret sergeant major
john Fischetti knows better than most
the physical and emotional cost of
service was it hard to ask for help yes
it was there's a lot of misunderstanding
with the younger soldiers they think
that if they tell the command or they
tell somebody they have a problem that
that's gonna look bad on them career
killer career killer yeah but the thing
is it's it's the furthest thing from the
truth instead a revolutionary approach
at the Tampa VA hospital is helping to
treat the unseen wounds of war CBS News
got an exclusive look at the treatment
called prep shorthand for post
deployment rehabilitation and evaluation
program how many service members have
traumatic brain injuries so it's been
estimated about 20% dr. Brian Merritt is
the medical director there a person or
an event or a situation that made you
think this has really been worth it for
me I would say seeing the patients with
their families afterwards because that's
what's going to be there regardless what
happens with their future or the
military if you go on your toes it'll
help the playdoh knows
using virtual reality technology the
therapy team retrains the brain after
battlefield trauma in Paris balance an
underwater treadmill reduces chronic
pain and rebuilds confidence I can
actually associate those things for many
this inpatient program is also the first
time they've actually met with a
therapist because it takes the emotion
it takes the feeling out of it
service members stay here 6 to 12 weeks
for what doctors call a holistic
approach it's like I'm peeling an onion
you take a layer at a time and each
layer you'll find a different problem
and that and you have to find that
solution it's like getting the help
becomes another mission it does deputy
commander for Special Operations
Vice Admiral Tim Szymanski said the
program is part of a culture shift in
the military folks are coming forward
and we're showing them that they can
return to duty the Tampa program only
has a dozen beds but there is new
momentum to expand so other war fighters
can heal beautiful I plan on being able
to influence my soldiers on the front
lines to help them to get the help they
need machete told us that he is working
on relationships at home after years of
keeping them at arm's length because he
wanted to shield them from the hurt he
was feeling such an important program
yeah and for people to speak up I liked
how he said at first I didn't even know
I needed the help that I needed it's so
important to talk and get it out in the
open and to know that this program
exists yeah yeah and unless those guys
come forward tell their stories it makes
it easier for the guys behind them to
diversity well the most important part
is people are listening